olivia wolken hat gefragt was eigentlich
mit unseren fünf gold passiert wenn wir
abnehmen
[Musik]
der begriff fensterbrett college von
ungefähr für chemiker ist eine
verbrennung eine reaktion einen wahren
schatz mit sauerstoff genauer gesagt
eine reaktion unter der abgabe von wärme
die bei der verbrennung von
kohlenwasserstoffen zum beispiel werden
bei den hohen temperaturen
kohlenstoffatome und die
wasserstoffatome kaum voneinander
gerissen und mit sauerstoff atome wieder
zusammen geschmissen krank ende bleiben
von den kohlenwasserstoffen so doch
kohlendioxid und wasser zumindest einer
vollständigen trennung in der presse
erfahren wie man eine wohnung
vollständige verbrennung entsteht zum
beispiel auf das riesige wurden
wohnungen ok aber was hat das jetzt mit
der fettverbrennung in unserem körper zu
tun
unser körper besteht zum teil aus den
unterlagen aber überlebenswichtigen
fläzen schweren aufgabe ist es energie
zu speichern
wenn man keine energie zb sich rissen
vorhandenen wechseln sind so ähnlich
aufgebaut wie normale zellen nur besteht
zu 90 prozent aus fett sie haben einfach
wirklich bald bestehend aus trikot zu
sehen so aus wie bestehen auf einem
kurzen stück das auch noch längere
kohlenwasserstoff hinten dran das sind
die fettsäuren kit hat viel energie eine
deutlich höhere energiedichte als
kohlenhydrate oder proteine diese
energie sitzt in den wohnungen zwischen
den kohlenstoffatom und kann freigesetzt
werden wenn die bindungen gebrochen
werden wenn wir länger nicht fressen
bekommen oder sport machen und wenn der
körper energie braucht während die
freaky friede in kleinere teile des
präsidenten stehen zunächst größter öl
und fett
diese kleineren teile können ihr zu
sprechen und in die blutbahn gelangen
dadurch schrumpfen
die plätz welt das heißt man kann fett
verbrennen fällen aber nicht sie werden
immer kleiner oder größer je nachdem ob
man zu oder abnimmt
jedenfalls die ohren wertvollen gehen in
die muskeln und die leber
dort werden die moleküle noch weiter
zerteilt wird am ende noch co2 und
wasser übrig bleiben also genau wie bei
einer klassischen verbrennung co2 atmen
wir aus wasser scheiden wir aus
im gegensatz zu einer klassischen
verbrennung verlaufen die reaktionen
nicht durch hitze sondern mit hilfe von
enzymen
außerdem ist er bei der trennung ein
molekül atp kategorie 3
das papier ist als energieträger einen
kraftstoff sozusagen für alle davon
energie kostet das wort oder auch nur so
sachen wie verdauung oder her zu sein
erinnert ihr euch noch an eine un reform
mit dem kaffee ich danke da ging es
darum was koche ich ihnen oder wie hier
macht von der waffen die rede
wenn wir vier adenosin haben werden wir
müde wird ihr woher das kommt vom atv
über allem was uns energie kostet
verbrauchen wir positiv htp am ende
davon kritisch bleibt es für das harte
musik voll cool oder
also nochmal klar der unseren
feststellen wenn ich sport machen oder
abnehmen peter z in kleinere teile
zerbrochen und die werden dann im
stoffwechsel wird co2 wasser und atp
umgewandelt wenn man darüber nachdenkt
ist ziemlich abgefahrenes unser körper
das macht und wirtschaft moleküle zu
zerbrechen
weltcup rennen macht unser körper einen
die meiste arbeit
mit ein bisschen sport unter die arme
greifen ich habe das müsste oder duschen
vielen dank olivia für deine frage wenn
ihr fragen habt schreibt in die
kommentare und wenn ihr nach diesem
körpereinsatz nicht abonniert dann hat
sie keine
[Musik]